the truth is for a lot of people that as
their responsibilities begin to increase
as they get older it becomes harder and
harder to train and I made a video
recently discussing this talking about
how on YouTube a lot of influencers a
lot of Fitness creators they discuss
Fitness and optimizing Health in a way
that's not really applicable to parents
a lot of YouTube seems to be aimed at
you know adolescence that video had
great engagement from other parents
quite a few people requested that I
create a follow-up video discussing some
of the strategies you can put into place
in order to maintain your physique
particularly your functional performance
as you get older and even to devise a
plan and I had a request on this on
patreon recently so I decided let's give
it a go then my wife and I aren't super
keen on having our children appear on
YouTube so for today's video we're using
a stand-in I'd like you to meet
Kell he's adopted yes the bionaire has
finally gone fully insane and if you're
not a parent then I do recommend maybe
sticking around because not only could
this help for you to relate a bit more
to the parents in your life and to
understand what they're going through
especially if you're a trainer and
you're someone who needs to train
parents and not only is it a good way to
prepare yourself for what might be in
your future but also many of these tips
will apply even if your someone is just
busy for other reasons if you're tired
for other reasons having kids is
exhausting but it's not the anything
that's exhausting so yeah stick around
and hopefully you'll find some useful
tips there too so first let's just
quickly recap why is it so challenging
to be a parent and stay in shape this is
something someone asked me recently
someone a bit younger who doesn't have
kids they said to me I appreciate that
being a parent is really tiring everyone
says it is I know that's true but why
what is it about being a parent that is
so tiring and this is one of those
things where at the time no answer came
to mind that was particularly satisfying
it's only afterwards where I thought
this and this and this and that's what I
should have said and the first and
biggest one is simply that there is zero
downtime as a parent you never get to
come home kick off your shoes and relax
so I'm going to be talking primarily
someone who goes to work and comes home
back to the kids for me I go to work I
come home and I might have had a long
busy stressful day and when I get home I
would love to just sit on the sofa and
relax but that just doesn't happen
because here's the thing my wife Hannah
she's been looking after the kids for
the last eight nine hours and she just
really wants a break so it's not fair
for me to come in and say I've had a
hard day and sit down because being with
the kids is much more tiring it's much
more mind-numbing so I have to take over
and play with the kids and of course
that's what I want to do as well because
I've been at work all day I've missed
them and this is where I get my quality
time but yeah if you've had a hard day
if you've been doing push-ups in the
woods and falling over and banged your
head then you suddenly have to be Daddy
horse running around with them on your
back you have to deal with their
arguments you have to sort out problems
then after that you have to cook and
prepare dinner then you have to feed the
kids whilst they make it really
difficult and you have to convince them
to eat their broccoli and whatever else
then you have to do the bedtime routine
which usually involves wrestling them
into their PJs and bathing them which is
extremely exhausting then you have to
get them to bed normally they don't want
to do that either so you're gonna have
to sit with them for ages then come
seven or eight o'clock when they finally
gone to sleep you still get to relax
because at this point you've achieved
nothing you've only just effectively
gotten home you're only just available
so now you need to do the washing up now
you need to do any tidying any clothes
washing you need to do any dusting you
need to fill out forms by the time we've
done that it's now 9 9 30. and then
you're completely exhausted and it all
starts again the next day and if you're
sick if you've injured yourself that
doesn't cut it because you know your
kids aren't going to give you a day off
so there's literally no day off even
when you go on holiday with the kids
they're still there and they still have
these demands so you get even more
exhausted even in the evening when the
kids have finally gone to bed and you've
done all those chores if you have the
energy still to work out well then
you're probably going to want to spend
some time with your partner and this is
really important because if all you do
is look after kids then not only is it
mind numbing you know you've done
nothing for you you've watched no TV
read no books played no games learned
nothing at the same time you're not
getting any quality time with your
partner and then on top of all that you
don't even get to sleep when you go to
sleep at night they're probably gonna
wake up in the middle of the night most
parents take it in turns which means at
best you're gonna get a good night's
sleep every other night night even if
they sleep through the night which does
happen on occasion they're going to wake
up at five six in the morning and yeah
you're just exhausted so yeah are you
beginning to see the problem and I know
that if you're a parent then I'm
preaching to the choir you get it and
there's just no time to recover and
that's the other thing having kids means
constantly bending over awkward angles
fighting wriggling children first thing
in the morning when you're tired it's a
recipe for injury so you're poorly
you're injured you're tired you've got
no time so then when someone says to you
hey you should take a cold shower first
thing in the morning and then meditate
for 10 minutes then go for a stroll I'm
like seriously so how do we stay in
shape as parents how do we stay in shape
when we have all these responsibilities
well the first thing I'm going to
recommend is just making your workouts
as convenient as practical as easy as
possible and thinking about your routine
and how you're going to fit that
training around that routine because
most parents will fall into some rather
repetitive routine which is one of the
only ways we're able to survive so for
example if you're choosing which gym you
want to go to then the most important
thing is the practicality and ease of
getting there so that means that no
matter what the facilities are the only
thing you should be considering is which
is nearest that's the one you should
join as a parent because that way if you
do only have time for a 20 minute
workout at the gym then you can get
there but you are also going to have to
learn to work out from home and I even
work out from this office but that's a
bit of a luxury you can work out from a
field you're going to need to learn to
work out in different places I've talked
about this in previous videos and in a
recent short but a great way to
accomplish this is to write a different
version of each workout for each Place
based on the equipment you've got so if
you're at the gym you might be doing
heavy military press but if you're at
home you might be doing Pike push-ups
that's a body weight shoulder exercise
the point is you want to be able to work
out wherever you are with whatever
you've got at the same time for each
workout have a few key exercises a few
key lifts that you consider to be the
most important so that if you only have
20 minutes to work out you get those
most important exercises done right at
the start and if you're doing that every
week then you're going to be kind of
okay so for me right now the most
important exercises are pull-ups and
Pike push-ups and if I can just do a
good set of pull-ups three times a week
and a good set of Pike push-ups three
times a week that's some pretty good
upper body development and for the legs
I'm doing squats if I can do those
three things it's better than nothing
and obviously the aim is that I do more
than that and usually I do but if that's
all you can do then that's better than
nothing for you the exercises will be
different but the point is to make that
distinction and what I also find really
useful and something I've talked about
again in the past is to make your
workouts modular and if you use my
training program super functional
training 2.0 there's a link in the
description to that which is a
functional training program for your
entire body that trains everything from
your ability to cardio to strength
endurance to max strength that has a
modular version and what I mean by
modular is that you break your workouts
into pieces so that for example you
might do your Mobility is a separate
workout you might do a few push
exercises as a separate workout you
might do a few core exercises as a
separate workout I'm gravitating now
more towards full body routines this is
great for parents because not only does
it mean you're going to find it much
easier to Target each muscle group more
than once a week but at the same time if
you miss a workout it's less disruptive
so with a full body routine you might
miss it but you didn't have to try and
recalibrate when you're going to push
legs cetera so I'm doing more full body
workouts which means I can take the push
section I can take the legs section I
can take the mobility section now I can
do them sporadically throughout the day
and most importantly by breaking your
workouts like this by training
throughout the day it massively
increases your energy levels and this
obviously is massive for parents so you
might think I'm tired so I need to rest
and sometimes that's true but very often
what you actually need to do is to be
more active because when you're more
active you get the blood flowing you get
your metabolism up you get the right
neurotransmitters being produced it just
wakes you up and gives you more energy
and this is one way that I managed to
stay kind of bubbly kind of bouncy in a
good mood for my kids even though a lot
of the time I'm exhausted for me it was
a lifesaver and it's something I still
do even now that I'm more strictly going
to the gym as part of my job what's also
really important here then is to have
the right equipment in your home in the
office wherever else and there's a few
different items that can make a big
difference here
so one of the very best pieces of
equipment you can get to train with from
home is push-up stands that double as
powerless so these push-up stands aren't
going to rock around when you're pushing
up on them they're nice and stable and
that means that I can do push-ups on
them which is fantastic if you want to
increase your range of motion perhaps if
you have an achy wrist but at the same
time these are great for performing hand
balancing movements if I want to do my
Pike push-ups with greater range of
motion if I want to do things like tuck
planche holds which I do if you want to
do handstands or l-sit these are perfect
for that and you've got kettlebells of
course most Home Gyms you're not going
to have a kind of rack with lots of
options here like this but if you don't
have space for many pieces of training
equipment then a kettlebell is a
fantastic option for doing quick
workouts because most people aren't
going to fit a power rack into their
home especially if they have kids having
a kettlebell means I can do things like
clean and press or clean and jerk or
snatches at the same time it's fantastic
for cardio and resistance cardio great
for building strong glutes and improving
those hinge mechanics and kettlebells
are fantastic for building kind of
functional strength that's useful as a
parent build grip strength from holding
onto the handle use movements in the
transverse plane the rotational plane
doing things like crossbody kettlebell
swings or Atlas swings you can use it
for carries like Farmers walks again to
build those traps you can carry your
kids around a kettlebell is just a
fantastic versatile tool that's really
great functional training fits into any
home and then for cardio and for weight
loss in particular jumping rope is
fantastic jumping rope is something you
can do anywhere as long as you've got a
high enough ceiling I recommend doing it
just outside but as long as you've got a
garden of some sort or you're able to
just stop by a field somewhere you can
jump rope and just 10 minutes you get a
workout and it's going to burn a whole
lot of calories and wake you up so
you've got more energy going forwards
and if you're looking to start jumping
rape then I highly recommend today's
sponsor which is crossroad now these
ropes are more expensive than your
regular ropes but there is a world of
difference and crossover offers a trial
period so you can try them out and if
you don't get on with them send them
back you'll get your money back there's
no risk involved but what you'll find is
that compared to other Apes these are
just more convenient and they're better
made they've got better spin mechanics
so they spin much more easily they last
you for years they don't get tangled up
so they're just ready to go and you pick
them up and there's loads of great
features with Crossroad one of the
biggest selling points and one of the
reasons I like them so much is that you
can attach different ropes so you have
heavier ropes if you want to increase
the resistance thereby burn more
calories thereby build some strength in
your shoulders they can jump around
Pizza very full body workout not just a
cardio workout we have much lighter ones
if you want to go a bit faster also very
useful are their amp ropes these are
their new smart ropes that let you do
things like count how many jumps you do
successfully but at the same time they
also sync with the app so you can follow
along with workouts and if you are a
parent who's just got 10 minutes you'll
be able to find something there that
will burn a set number of calories in a
certain amount of time whilst also
teaching new cool techniques whilst also
improving your functional performance
and this is just a really great way to
track your progress have fun training
and to do it in a short amount of time
if you use the discount code and get 15
off your order you'll find a link in the
description down below thanks again to
crossrate for sponsoring this video and
now on with the show so yeah keep a few
of these items around the house and make
it much easier for you to get in these
kind of 10 20 minute workouts wherever
you can and at the same time I do highly
recommend that you focus a little bit
more on functional training and of
course I'm going to say that I'm biased
but I think functional training becomes
really important whenever life gets
tough especially when it gets physically
tough as a parent like I say you're
going to be lifting lots of awkward
shapes you're going to be folding up the
pram and getting it into the boot you're
going to be Jefferson curling your kids
out of their cot whilst they're
wriggling and fighting you and it's two
o'clock in the morning these are all
recipes for injury and especially if
you're tired from a workout you've done
the previous day and if your workout is
only focusing on the mirror muscles and
if you're out of shape in terms of
cardio then it becomes even more likely
that you're going to injure yourself so
especially if you're a soon to be parent
then training in a way that's going to
fortify your body and prepare you for
this is a really good idea just a few
exercises that I highly recommend are
glute Bridges these are great for
building stronger glutes I've talked
recently about sandbag carries a sandbag
carry means basically carrying a bag in
front of you there's an awkward shape
and walking for a distance which is
exactly what you're going to be doing
when you're carrying your kids around
running is a great idea for the
additional walking you're going to be
doing doing crawls and kick sets and
crab is great for all the playing on the
floor you're going to be doing
practicing your deep body weight squat I
highly recommend doing some training in
the transverse plane and that means
things like Wood Choppers and those
Jefferson curls to strengthen up the
back you want to strengthen your knees
with things like Hindu squats
squats if you can do it atg split Squat
and yeah improving your full body
Mobility add those things to your
routine as you prepare to be a parent or
if you're already a parent who's
struggling and you should find your
body's a bit more fortified against some
of the stresses that come from being a
parent and I will include a completely
free modular program that parents can
try out in the link in the description
down below I hope you found that useful
and remember this is the priority now
and if you do lose a little bit of
performance that's absolutely fine it's
not not the end of the world as long as
you're maintaining your Fitness
throughout this time you're going to be
just fine and probably in a better shape
than a lot of people
so you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share it around and let
me know in the comments down below if
you're a parent and if so what have been
some of the tips that have helped you to
keep training even though it's yeah
really challenging like I say guys this
was actually a request from a patreon
member so if you'd like to put in
requests and talk to me a bit more
easily then head over to the patreon and
get involved at the same time I've just
shared over there my own personal
workout this is my exact training plan
and it's gonna be updated live as that
changes you also get early videos there
without the ad breaks and sponsors so
yeah check it out either way guys thank
you so much for watching this one and
I'll see you next time
bye for now